all right people this is my last direct
message of 2017 so hopefully I'll make
it a good one last week we put up five
shows in five days for Ruben Report
YouTube week this week we've gotten I
sit down with former National Public
Radio CEO Ken Stern and next week we'll
be highlighting some of my favorite
episodes of the year today's direct
message is going to be quicken to the
point with the incredible gratitude and
a humble heart I want to thank all of
you who helped make 2017 such a
memorable year here at the Rubin report
the ride to get here from 12 years of
stand-up comedy in New York City to my
pop culture radio show at Sirius XM to
hosting on The Young Turks to joining my
friend and mentor Larry King on Ora TV
and finally to this independent show
funded by you has been a long and
winding journey one which I wouldn't
trade in for anything it's only been a
year and a half since we made the move
to independence and as some of you have
heard me say the night before we
launched on patreon I literally thought
that my career as well as the careers of
my team might actually be over
fortunately within hours of launching we
quickly realized that not only was it
not over but we were just at the
beginning in the 18 months since then I
bought a home in which we built this
totally professional home studio we
expanded the team behind the scenes the
show absolutely exploded with almost
400,000 new subscribers and most
importantly we've continued to have
honest civil conversation that hopefully
has left you feeling a little more
enlightened and a lot less alone this
year we did an on-location shoot with
ayaan Hirsi Ali I interviewed Richard
Dawkins in front of a live studio
audience in New York City we helped put
important voices fighting for academic
freedom on the map like Jordan Petersen
Brett Weinstein and Lindsay Shepherd we
hosted a conversation on religion and
morality with Dennis Prager and Michael
Shermer we introduced you to incredible
voices fighting for liberalism like
Yasmin Muhammad and Lube de Achmed we
also introduced you to some previous
guests like Peter bagozzi and Eric
Weinstein and GAD said all of whom who
are great guests but more importantly
have become great friends of mine as
well and of course we also hosted the
infamous debate between
Blair White and Candace Owens which got
me trending on Twitter for the first
time in my life
hashtag save Dave your support also
allowed me to take some time off in
August to work on my book and take 30
truly life-changing days off the grid in
an age when we never get off our devices
when we're slammed with news about
terrorism right after we scroll past a
cat video and a picture of your high
school friends kid you guys gave me the
greatest gift I could possibly ask for a
little time to reset and to rejuvenate
and in exchange for you giving me some
of that precious time we made sure to
have all new shows for you throughout
August ready to roll while we were gone
I've got a long list of people to thank
for making everything happen here but I
have to give personal shoutouts to David
- a mirror - Alexis - Talia and even -
Emma there's an incredible amount of
work that goes into producing these
shows and the only reason that it looks
so easy is because of the team that I
have making it look just that way I also
want to give a special shout out to
those of you who provide us with monthly
support on patreon and on PayPal or who
have done one-time donations via Bitcoin
your support not only keeps us
independent but has given me the luxury
of saying no to several big-money offers
this year as long as that support
remains I see no reason to change that
and I promise that I will do my best to
make sure that your continued support is
well worth it and of course thanks to
all of you who watch share and like
these videos we've never put a dollar
into YouTube ads but the show continues
to grow because you helped it do so the
emails that I get from you saying how
you're putting the ideas we discuss your
into action or changing what you believe
because of something you've heard or
just talking to people in a new way
because of the tone we've set here is
incredibly inspiring and I'm sorry if I
don't write everyone back immediately
trust me I'm trying so thank you thank
you and thank you this time of year is
when we give thanks and show gratitude
and it's all of you who have given me so
much to be thankful and grateful for I
look forward to kicking off 2018 with
you soon enough but in the meantime
Merry Christmas Happy Hanukkah happy New
Year and may the force be with you
you